this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
let's talk about denaturation so what is
denaturation or denaturation it is the
loss or destruction of a protein
structure or native conformation which
basically turns into a loss of function
as a result and a lot of the times
denaturation specifically refers to the
destruction of secondary tertiary and
quaternary structure and not necessarily
primary structure because that holds
together the peptide bonds basically
anything that ruins secondary tertiary
and quaternary structure is considered
denaturation although if you have an
enzyme called a protease which is a
proteolytic enzyme it cuts up proteins
you're going to destroy that protein
okay so you if you if the iteration is
defined simply as the loss or
destruction of a protein structure and
consequently its function then you could
include that as well okay depending on
who you talk to
okay so let's talk about some agents
that can actually call it the iteration
or denaturing agents so the first one
acids or bases or basically just changes
in pH and that's because variations in
pH or hydrogen ion concentration can
alter titratable groups whether they're
protonated or deprotonated and therefore
can disrupt electrostatic interactions
electrostatic interactions which of
course hold together tertiary and prime
and quaternary structure okay so if you
have for example an aspartate and a
lysine that are next to each other at a
pH of 7.4 the aspartate is deprotonated
and negatively charged the lysine is
protonated and positively charged
there's an attraction between them okay
these opposite charges attract they want
to come closer together but let's just
say it's kind of exaggerated the point
here we take the pH and we go from seven
point four two to one so we make it
really really acidic so we're adding a
bunch of protons
we're adding a bunch if we're adding a
bunch of protons to decrease that pH
then we're gonna protonate groups and so
with a pH that low aspartate ends up
getting protonated because of course
lysine is already protonated and now the
attraction that was there is no longer
nearly as strong because at first you've
got a positive and negative charge
opposite charges attract but here you
have a positive charge and something
that's neutral so this positively
charged lysine is not nearly as
attracted to this as part 2 as it was
before now that's just one example of
one interaction here we have an
aspartate and here we have a lysine so
this is negatively charged and this is
positively charged we have an
electrostatic interaction right here in
this area they're specifically attracted
to each other and that attraction is
holding this region of the protein
together so you can imagine that if a pH
change occurs here that alters the
interaction between these guys that can
disrupt the structure here locally you
can imagine that if this occurs on a
greater scale for the you know with with
a bunch of different side chains in a
protein that protein structure can can
be severely altered and of course the
function can be lost ok so this is why
acidosis and alkalosis are are important
and and and dangerous right if the pH
changes in our in our in our body
different regions of course how
different pH is for instance our blood
is around 7.4 the pH and our stomach is
around 1 or 2 those there are optimal pH
is 2 given the circumstances and if
those pH has changed too much that can
that can denature the proteins that are
in that area or in that in that region
and that of course is bad ok and
dangerous ok so next up detergents
detergents are amphipathic or
amphiphilic molecules which basically
means that they have polar and nonpolar
portions they are amphipathic are a few
filling molecules that can orient their
hydrophobic portions to associate with
the hydrophobic portions or side chains
of amino acids in a protein
therefore disrupting hydrophobic
interaction
okay and then essentially they'll rip
apart a protein so this is a tertiary or
quaternary structure because hydrophobic
interactions holds the other tertiary
and quaternary structure some detergents
have charged portions they're not just
polar or nonpolar they actually charge
and if that's the case they can act they
can actually even though to a probably a
much smaller extent they can disrupt
electrostatic interactions but not all
detergents are like that
so here SDS or sodium dodo death Odessa
Lord of diesel sulfate order this means
twelve dog deck that's 12 and so there's
12 carbons here okay
and in that sulfate group and then that
sodium ion right here so that's that is
a detergent and it's amphipathic because
we have this nonpolar portion here this
nonpolar tail and then we have this
polar head group and it's very similar
to a fatty acid good fatty acids are
just they had that long prologue that in
fact it basically is a fatty acid except
that it's not a carboxylic acid it's a
sulfuric acid up here the point is that
there's a nonpolar portion in the polar
portion and if you have these kind of
like fatty acids they kind of orient
themselves into these little spherical
my seals now this is obviously not I
didn't draw this in a spherical way but
it's kind of like a slice okay I
mentioned kind of imagining a protein
before like an orange slice or like an
orange rather and then taking a slice of
it if you have an orange the peel is
exposed to the outside and then the
fruity part isn't so with the micelle
it's kind of like that when you have
like fatty acids or like detergents like
this the nonpolar portions kind of
orient themselves towards being in the
center and then the surface is just the
polar polar groups and so anything
nonpolar will kind of just hang out here
now
that's assuming of course that it's in
an aqueous environment
okay so there's water all around now how
does this disrupt or mess up a protein
structure well
proteins let's say that they're in oops
this protein let's say it's in an
aqueous environment like most proteins
are and then we add this micelle or this
detergent and so what'll happen is that
the detergents maybe we don't add like a
ton of it and they're all like in my
cells but let's say we add some and we
have these these portions kind of
hanging out and they don't want to be
out and about like this they don't want
to be in that hydrophilic space so what
they're gonna do is they're gonna find
whatever they can it's a non-polar and
just snag it and hang on to it so you
can imagine that if there's enough of
these detergent particles they'll go
through and dig into this protein and
and kind of rip it out from the inside
out so as to have these nonpolar
portions interact with the nonpolar
interior of this protein so it will kind
of get ripped out and you will have
these little detergent particles
interacting with the nonpolar portions
of this protein maybe that'll just take
it from looking like that the proteins
originally to making it look something
like like this who knows exactly what
it'll look like but the point is that
its structure will be ruined and of
course consequently its function
here's a quick 3d visual what's going on
with SDS so here that's the s and we've
got its nonpolar tail it wants to be on
the interior of that protein in the
hydrophobic space not out in the
hydrophilic space so it's gonna stab its
way in as are all the rest of these SDS
is and their hydrophobic tails are going
to make their way into the interior
notice though that the hydrophilic
portion of the SDS here remains on the
exterior surface okay if we zoom in we
could see the hydrophobic tails from the
SDS azar interacting with the interior
of this protein which is held together
in large part by the hydrophobic
interactions on the inside so these
hydrophobic tails basically disrupt the
hydrophobic interactions on the interior
that protein and rip the protein apart
from the inside out
so so yes that's kind of the idea there
with detergents is that they'll destroy
those hydrophobic interactions and and
kind of unfold the protein okay yeah so
SDS is an example also a lot of
household cleaners are detergents like I
mean and and that they're they're toxic
one of the reasons they're toxic as
detergents is that they can they can do
this to proteins okay so next up heat
okay so heat pretty much disrupts or
breaks hydrogen bonds and so hydrogen
bonds hold together secondary tertiary
and quaternary structures so all those
can be ruined by excessive amounts of
heat so here I've drawn a serine with
its Oh H group sidechain and then
another serine here and draw the whole
amino acid but we can see here that
there's a hydrogen bond that that is
holding these guys together right there
and if we add enough heat the the the
atoms these molecules will vibrate and
all that higher kinetic energy and
they'll move apart and so what you use
that the hydrogen bond that used to be
there between them will be broken okay
and this has happens when we cook fry oh
if you cook an egg you can actually see
the color change you can see it cook
cooking and cooking meat for example
also if you have like a steak for
example um it starts off this really red
sort of squishy
maybe squishy is not the best word but
when you grill a steak for example the
consistency changes the color change is
all these different things change and so
the proteins are being denatured okay
also he is using the DNA sharing agent
when it comes to sterilizing medical
equipment especially surgical supplies
they basically they just cook them and
like these in these machines that take
him to a really really really high
temperature so as to kill any
potentially infectious organisms on them
okay next up hydrogen bond donors or
acceptors so these are basically
molecules that can participate well
molecules that can participate in
hydrogen bonds can basically get in the
way of existing hydrogen bonds and
proteins and they can end up destroying
those hydrogen bonds so again we're
talking about something that can disrupt
hydrogen bonds so hydrogen bonds hold
together secondary tertiary and
quaternary structures so all those can
be disrupted by the molecules that can
do this one prime example is urea and
urea can hydrogen bond extensively
because of its lone pairs on the oxygen
up here that can be involved as
hydrogen-bond acceptors and the
hydrogen's on these attached to the
nitrogen here can act as a CH bond
donors so what can happen is they can
kind of sneak their way in between
existing hydrogen bonds for example
again I'm using the example I was to see
amines hydrogen bonding here and there
of course is the D hydrogen bond so if
you add your via to this situation here
it can kind of squeeze its way in there
and end up hydrogen bonding here with
this the searing and hydrogen bond here
with this serine over here and so now
we've got urea hydrogen bonding with
with with these two Syrian groups so the
point is that this hydrogen bond that we
began with has been destroyed and this
that's been replaced with an H bond here
and an H bond here but we end up
destroying the one that we originally
had and so that will of course have an
impact on that protein structure
especially if it's to a great extent
okay
so next up producing agents
okay so reducing agents they reduce or
break disulfide bonds or disulfide
bridges into separate thigh all groups
okay separate files and it's of course
can you structure she or a quaternary
structure cuz disulfide bridges can hold
tertiary or quaternary structure
together so here I have a disulfide
bridge I had the bond between these two
sulfur's on these separate cysteines
okay if I add a reducing agent that'll
split them apart and we'll have those
two separate file groups that's it's
just this is a thigh all here and this
is a thigh all helped but now they're
separate okay and so if I want to reform
if I want to reform a disulfide bridge I
can oxidize it now that the issue is
that actually before I get into that an
example of a reducing agent is beta
mercaptoethanol or two more cap-toe
ethanol a little destroy disulfide
bridges like this okay and one issue is
that you can reform disulfide bridges
but you won't necessarily reform the
same disulfide bonds that were already
there if you have a protein that has
multiple disulfide bridges and you add a
reducing agent and then you you break
all those disulfide bonds and you add an
oxidizing agent it may not fold right
back into the perfect position because
you might have different disulfide
bridges forming between different
systems and won't necessarily be like
cysteine to maybe was originally bound
to cysteine 147 but then when you break
that cysteine to my end up being
somewhere totally away from 147 if you
re oxidized it Assisting to my form a
disulfide bridge with 1638 who knows so
here's a visual to explain what I just
described
we've got insulin here and insulin has
three disulfide bridges okay one right
here one right here and one up here now
if you had a reducing agent it's gonna
go through and destroy those disulfide
bridges and it will subsequently
denature the protein
now if you afterwards add some sort of
oxidizing agent you will allow disulfide
bridges to reform however you don't know
that you will necessarily reform this
specific that's all five bridge between
these two cysteines
right you might not reform that you
might not reform the one between these
two or the one that was between these
two and even if you manage to form those
exact same pairs there's no telling how
the rest of the molecule might be
oriented so basically there's no way to
undo the denaturation the idea is that
it's not easy to just undo a
denaturation like this okay in fact
inside just with with reusing agents
there's just denaturation of proteins in
general it's it's pretty much impossible
to to undo okay next up heavy metals
okay so heavy metals often exist as
metal ions okay and they are
specifically cations so they're
positively charged and thus they disrupt
electrostatic interactions
okay so that'll be tertiary quaternary
structure they can also disrupt
disulfide bonds and because of their
affinity for sulfur okay again that's
the tertiary or quaternary structure so
some examples of heavy metals are like
lead mercury silver and so just to kind
of use a similar example that we did
last time if we have a pH of 7.4 we have
a sparked a and lysine next to each
other that's that attraction between
them because of the opposite charges but
if you add in a silver that's silver ion
being positively charged might want to
hang out with the negatively charged
aspartate and there's an attraction
there it'll disrupt the interaction that
was there between that s party and
lysine so of course if that happens to a
great enough extent that can really
screw up the protein structure also
heavy metals tend to have a really high
attraction for for cystines now here
I've drawn it just being attracted to a
Thyle group so we can see here this kind
of displaces the
that's their that hydrogen comes off as
an ion but it can do the same thing with
two cysteines that are bound together
and as I saw if I'd bond so heavy metals
can disrupt electrostatic interactions
and I sulfide bridges and therefore
tertiary and quaternary structure so
heavy metal poisoning is the thing heavy
metal toxicity you might hear it
referred to when you have so there are
some metals that exist in trace amounts
in our bodies and it's it's it's very
possible that the levels of those those
heavy metals can get too high and
depending on the metal the symptoms will
vary so I can't give like a
one-size-fits-all explanation for having
a metal poisoning at least not here in
this video but one of the treatments for
a lot of different heavy metal poisoning
is chelation therapy and chelation
therapy is just the idea of adding
chelating agents which are electron
donating groups and given that metal
ions are positively charged they want
the they react well with things that are
negatively charged Hey aka electrons so
electron donating groups on these
chelating agents will basically attack
these metals kind of take them off these
proteins and then when they bond
together that that they form like this
coordinate covalent complex and that
that can be safely excreted in the urine
okay now of course that's a quick
one-size-fits-all answer there's
obviously a lot more to it than what I
mentioned here but I figured I'd mention
it here since it's to some extent
relevant to what we're talking about
anyway I hope that video was helpful as
far as denaturation goes thank you for
watching